Kennedy family members call RFK Jr's
independent bid dangerous to our country
to be fair they were doing that before
they really don't like him Christmas and
Thanksgiving would be super awkward for
the Kennedy family this year yep they
strip votes away from can you imagine
like having Thanksgiving with your
family and you're a former Governor your
brother is a senator your other
brother's running for president and
you're just like you know you shouldn't
be running for president like well I'm
going it's like guys know politics at
the table Yeah Yeah they he saying his
dad would have them all talk politics
Bobby or like I think his grandpa would
have his dad and his uncle John and and
I mean his spee he's Nam dropping
everybody because they really did have
such a Dynasty uh in his life I mean
it's not a joke I just can't imagine you
know working out like hey you're not
invited to Thanksgiving this year
because you're running for president as
a third party candidate they're like
cool I didn't want to go anyways yeah I
he's actually said his family disagrees
with him politically but they get along
and he has a bunch of uh pretty
mainstream I mean not that Hollywood is
where should put all your your interest
but he has a lot of celebrity followers
isn't it like Woody harelson he at the
concert with I can't remember his name
at the top of my head but you know RFK
has appeal in a way that Biden does not
in a lot of aspects of culture his wife
is super famous actor Cheryl Hines from
Curb Your Enthusiasm lar I'm just going
to say it her outfit today was great I
would be happy to have her come on as a
first lady very stylish what was her
outfit she wore this like white double
double breasted uh button down suit and
it just she looked classy I can't I
can't help it I don't really want her
husband to be president but I'm happy
that he's in the race we're going to get
some great great moments from her I've
always liked this girl she's a great
actor man she anchored that show Kirby
Your
Enthusiasm and Cheryl his wife is this
it yeah but that's not today's picture
I'll find it oh right yeah I'm trying to
find it you just look up Sher oh her
dress apparently it's not the thing the
mainstream media wants to report on
That's So Rude of them yeah I know you
know I'm over here you trying to have a
serious news program and let people know
the clothing of slowly convert IRL to a
fashion review program thank you so much
everybody uh what do you think Cheryl
looks like it seems like um she has no
political Acumen I can't tell for sure
but she seems like she's like a normie
actor like not Normie but she's like
outside the the whole thing do you think
that's good was it this yes oh okay I
mean that's kind of basic it's basic but
it's white it's pretty it's fitted well
she doesn't look overdone she doesn't
like to sh too hard I I I I just I don't
get what the argument is as to why Trump
voters would choose Kennedy I just don't
get it look I'm especially because we
got Melania I I I'm in a position where
it's like I've been saying I'm 51% for
Trump he's the best option that we have
I hope he fires people I think his
foreign policy was was the best we've
seen of my lifetime but I think that
there are Character defects of the guy
and it's like obviously there could be
better when I say 51 I'm basically
saying as far as presidents go being a
net positive is a really powerful thing
for me to say but J RFK Jr it's like oh
he's cool like I'm glad he's speaking up
against like the lock down stuff
but I would never vote for the guy how
much I was going to ask you James like
how much of of the president's value and
effectivity is like based is around that
one guy and around how much of it is
around the people he surrounds himself
with well I think it's been a trend in
American politics since FDR of the
presidency becoming more and more
ceremonial over time to the point today
where today's president has a 100th the
power that FDR did uh Curtis yarin has
talked about that a lot um the state has
become a massive problem and the people
truly pulling the levers of Power are
kind of this expert class at the top of
the bureaucracy that of course leans
left and is permanent you know they have
Civil Service
protections and it makes it hard for a
president to control the bureaucracy and
control the policy and it it's not just
for Republicans it's for Democrats too
although the bureaucracy just tends to
agree with them more it's kind of just a
coincidence is that why you got involved
with your project with heritage
yeah that's the idea behind project 2025
at Heritage actually which is basically
an effort to get the Personnel right
this next Administration and also an
effort to make sure that the bureaucrats
that have the true levers of power in
our bureaucracy are able to be held
accountable that doesn't mean we're
going to fire all of them but if
somebody is obstructing policy it's
making sure that person can be fired
because you know all these candidates
love to talk about what they're going to
do but if you don't first get the
bureaucracy under control you can't do
anything else so I imagine the
president's pretty neutered when it
comes to that but like what with a good
staff with a good like what would be an
example like what are the top three or
five roles that the president would need
to surround him or herself with like
what are the top five powerful roles
that they would pick and put I Know
Chief of Staff would be one of them
chief of staff is extremely important I
think I don't think it's necessarily the
roles I think it's the action the
president would need to take there is a
massive barrier between the president
and his own cabinet secretaries so
there's a White House bureaucracy within
the White House itself and they kind of
serve as this management barrier where
they they tell the president's cabinet
secretaries what to do instead of the
president directly and this this
management bureaucracy was created under
FDR and it's only grown bigger and
bigger so I think the next president
needs to do things like kick the
National Security Council permanent
bureaucrat staff out of the White House
on day one do things like that you know
make sure that your cabinate secretaries
are being told by you solely what to do
there's too many middlemen that the
president has so if you cut down on
these layers of bureaucracy and tell
your decision makers exactly what to do
that's that's kind of the way of
managing it and the other thing is the
president needs to delegate less and
follow up more that that's the key to
all of this because these bureaucrats
thrive in the shadows they don't want to
be confronted yeah if if the president
and his cabinet secretaries dig into
these agencies they are going to figure
out how things are really run and
they're going to get a better handle on
this stuff why did FDR create this
managerial class why did he put people
in in the middle so FDR was spinning up
all these new agencies in the 30s dur
during the New Deal and he wanted to put
in place a system that would last after
he left so he did this thing where he
got all these Progressive academics to
come up with a plan for how can I um
better better make this administrative
State work and these Progressive
academics base their plan on the
monarchies in Europe which had massive
bureaucracies when when the United
States didn't and FDR took their plan
and he implemented it and so it's this
idea of a permanent expert class an
expert class that keeps the policies
going no matter who the president is
it's the antithesis of democracy was it
because he was getting bribed by like
special interests and it was like favors
or was it because he couldn't run the
government properly to to win the world
war that he needed to fight uh what what
was his motivation like I think it's I
think it's more IDE I think it's
ideological more than anything else it's
just always been this left-wing idea
that we need government by an expert
class yeah it's like the maner
revolution M people refer to as
so what are you guys specifically doing
to combat this issue so there's the
there's a lot of things the president
can do but basically all the tools the
president has are in the civil service
reform Act of 1978 which actually was
passed by Congress to help the president
better control the Deep State because it
had become such a problem and it created
an agency called the office of personnel
management and they're supposed to
manage the
bureaucrats but what's happened over
time is that agency that was created got
captured by the bureaucrats themselves
so it's totally captured so you have to
take back that agency and then use the
legal authorities that that you have
which there are many you know people
know about the schedule F executive
order they're familiar with that that's
one of like 10 things the president can
start to do to hold the the bureaucracy
accountable so you think going in and
firing everyone maybe isn't is not the
right move but to go in and be very
selective about who and what to remove
or do you think more of just a broad
sweeping 75% reduction of Workforce
among the managerial class what do you
think is more effective I think you need
to do uh parts of both so you need to do
reductions in force where you get rid of
these non-essential workers the
non-essential bureaucracy I like to say
there's a deep State at the top that's
the leftwing expert class but then
there's like the DMV state below them
and these are like the millions of
unionized civil service protected
employees it's 2.25 million employees
and the president can only hire and fire
at will 4,000 of them so 99.9% of his
own employees he can't fire so you have
to you know get rid of the non-essential
ones and you can use reduction Force
exercises which is just a fancy term for
Mass government layoffs to do that but
then at the top it's more you know
picking apart um certain places where
the bureaucracy has a hold like the
state department you need to go in and
tear that place apart if people are
resisting you need to fire them um but
there's there's a lot of nuances to it
how would you implement reduction Force
exercises you would look at the parts of
the federal government that are truly
non-essential and it's funny because we
already have a list of these positions
when it when the government shuts down
all the non-essential workers go home
and we have this list that we like are
like you're not even that important
leave exactly exactly and so you're not
going to fire all those people but what
do it being non-essential mean it means
they're non-essential in some way yeah
is there like an start from there and
look at that is would it be an executive
order that would be like this would put
it into action or something this this
agency uh office of personnel management
would do it so for example on day one
you could say we're doing a reduction in
force to get rid of all the diversity
equity and inclusion offices across the
federal government and let's just start
there I wish let's just start there wish
dude it's a good place to start that's
how you got your job Serge right yeah
right that's how I got my job and that's
because you can't fire them individually
you've got to reduce the force somehow
Vivic was get around exactly it gets
around service put them all in the
Illusions just be like what Permanent
Vacation enjoy yourself no but I mean
get a nice house one one one thing we
can do is use as an opportunity to
develop areas that need development so
by putting them in Alaska we then have
to fund the creation of cities and towns
most of the people aren't going to want
to be there and so then what we'll do is
we'll just you know look for oil and
things like that and our own land I
think Stalin did that with Siberia
although I don't think the oil I I don't
if they got treated very well you pick
pick a place that needs development you
know start putting the offices there
what is your concern with mass layoffs
like um I know that in Iraq when we
invaded we disbanded the bath party and
said you can never serve in government
again and they all formed Isis basically
formed terrorist cells cuz they're like
what else can we do Connection in the
military bored yeah have this vision of
like American bureaucrats who get laid
off being like well now we're going to
organize into I'm not even joking cuz
they've got friends in the military our
own domestic terrorism is just laid off
yeah they join antifa Trump wins they
get fired now they're broke and they're
angry and they go become anti
recruitment spikes when we lay them off
maybe we shouldn't lay them off that's a
that's a very comping relocate them
first to the uans as close to Japan as
possible what let me let me pull this up
do you think there's a a risk that they
could form some sort of radical um like
NGO or something the utions are Liberia
forrat I think we do need Mass layoffs
for the record I think we do need Mass
layoffs thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net